Yeah,
no,
I mean it's a company of a,
of a,
of a famous people have people that want
to be famous with blurbs all around it
and it's supposed to be.
And uh,
you know,
that's supposed to be creativity in
journalism.
My God,
it's unbelievable.
It's shocking.
I mean,
how can happen 200 magazines,
you know,
do the same cover,
that that's always there and advertise
to go home and watch advertise.
I watch the commercials on TV and I
really,
I'm,
I'm not kidding,
I don't,
I don't really understand what,
what the hell.
I mean half of them,
I don't understand what they're talking
about and,
and most people don't understand,
even if they see something that they
kind of enjoy,
they don't remember the name of the
product,
you know?
So I mean,
I think,
uh,
I don't,
I don't see any,
I mean these people to keep talking
about it.
We're on the advent of coming up with
the creative evolution.
I don't see it,
you know,
I don't.
At the same time,
I know there's got to be talent that
they add on.
I'm not sure who it was telling them
what to do.
Yeah,
you have to have an understanding.
You have to understand,
have an understanding that everything
that I go back to what I said before,
everything you do it.
You have to have a solar farm.
If you come up with an idea,
a big idea it if you,
if you show it to somebody,
your wife,
your friend or a client,
they should go,
holy shit.
They should your head coach and go back
and forth.
You know,
it should be such and such a surprising
idea.
The only chance you have to do anything.
That's bullshit.
I has to be a shock when you first see
it.
You know,
and what people do is they,
they,
they just.
So the,
so the work is so unambitious,
you know,
a television commercial is a little
films,
you know,
something's going on and you don't know
what's going on and just say,
well what is it about?
And then you're looking for who the
client is.
And then when you see it you say,
oh,
I don't get it.
No,
I'm sorry,
I tried to.
It's a wasteland of a creativity,
unfortunately,
and I can't believe they're hidden
talent that day because I know I pay
people.
I have fans who profess your love of my
work,
et Cetera,
to kind of be something you to learn
from it.
I went,
they got to be learning from it is that
when you do something,
it should be an issue.
We had not got idea,
you know,
and,
and in most cases,
certainly in
certainly in an editorial and in which I
already did for 10 years for it,
for esquire and I and now in the museum
or not,
but,
uh,
but you have to eat when you're.
Every cover is when it hit,
when it was on a newsstand.
Peep some people.
What?
I mean,
the culture went ape shit on some of
them.
They looked at anybody.
Well,
um,
you know,
go to a new standard today.
You
never forget about something being
culturally being a culture busta.
There's nothing there that you could
possibly remember.
There's an ad today and about hearst
there today,
but with three magazines I talk about
they're getting awards,
etc. Etc.
And you look at thE cupboards and uh,
uh,
I don't know nothing,
you know,
they're all the same cover,
you know?
Well,
that's the,
that's the big problem,
you know,
I mean,
I'm talking about people or about a
young designers not,
not being ambitious enough,
et cetera,
et cetera.
One of the problems is,
is that,
you know,
certainly in,
in magazine design,
there's a lot of terrific talent,
uh,
doing editorial.
I meAn,
when you get this society publication
designer sends,
there were awards every year ago,
a book,
you know,
and uh,
and you'll look through it and it's a
lot of terrific threads in it,
a lot of exciting stuff going on.
You know,
there's talent there and then they show
the best coverage of the year.
And then at the end,
nothing,
you know.